la cloche de la tour de la paix a sonné
99 fois pour les 99 ans du prince philip
le prince philip était un époux un père
un grand père et un arrière grand père
bien aimé un hommage pour l'homme qui a
entretenu une longue relation avec le
canada en 1951 il a accompagné la
princesse elizabeth pour son voyage
inaugural en sol canadien depuis le dieu
d'edimbourg a visité le pays une
cinquantaine de fois a été témoin de
moments marquants de l'histoire
canadienne a connu une douzaine de
premier ministre jean chrétien se
souvient de son humour et de son franc
parler quand j'ai vu la première fois
j'ai tiges votre altesse royale vous
parlait bien français pour un anglais il
m'a répondu je ne suis pas un anglais et
je parlais français avant votre
naissance je ne connais ma réponse je
vous remercie pour votre chaleureux
les visites du prince philip était
toujours remarqué comme celle ci à
l'université de sherbrooke à la fin des
années 80 préparer les jeunes dotés d'un
potentiel supérieur
le premier ministre du québec a réagi
sur twitter je tiens à offrir mes
sincères condoléances à la reine
elizabeth 2 aux membres de sa famille
ainsi qu'au peuple britannique
les drapeaux canadiens sont en berne sur
les édifices fédéraux celui du québec à
l'assemblée nationale le sera aussi le
jour des funérailles du prince philip
un geste que déplore le chef du parti
québécois tout en offrant nos
condoléances à sa famille
nous croyons que le peuple québécois n'a
absolument pas à mettre le drapeau qui
flotte sur son assemblée nationale en
berne pour le décès de s'ouvre et
étrangers écrit-il
figure controversée pour les un modèle
pour les autres
enfin été marquée par un sens plus
devoirs et des responsabilités
vraiment vraiment qui n'a jamais failli
à sa tâche
colonel en chef honoraire de plusieurs
unités militaires canadiennes il s'est
aussi investi pour encourager
l'excellence chez les jeunes certains se
souviennent du personnage public mais
aussi de l'homme privé qui cachait
certaine déception qui avait le
sentiment d'être mal aimés peu reconnue
pour ses idées porte avant gardiste sa
dernière visite il y a huit ans était
plus sobre que sa première une cérémonie
intime où il a été le premier à recevoir
le titre de compagnon extraordinaire de
l'ordre du canada
symbole des liens qu'il a tissés avec le
pays au cours des 70 dernières années
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa